the case of the tampa bay rays it's
going to be left-hander ridge hill
taking the mound tonight making his
third start of the season so here is
jose trevino
a little ground ball second base
one there first base two and the rays
erase the lead off single
four six three on the double play
jordan working on four days rest he went
four and a third last time against the
padres
curveball and he got him swinging
meadows couldn't stop himself and
there's the first out
of the inning
and got him swinging boy that was a
pretty nifty bottom of the first for
jordan lyles under the second inning no
score elderly garcia leads it off
ground ball
diving stop rosso up and the throw
got him in first base outstanding play
by mike rosso down there third we'll
stamp it with the star
comes early here on that hot shot
off the bat of garcia and a nice play
by brasso two outs for solac
solat smashes one out to center field
how far will it carry it is gone
a home run
solac to the deepest part of the park
and he's put the rangers on the board
first tonight
it's one nothing
jordan lyles takes the lead to the mound
and works to yandy diaz he smacks one
hard to short it's knocked down by
connor falafa who throws him out a high
throw in nate lowe manuel margot
290 hitter oh and two here comes
swing and a miss on a curveball he
strikes out margot on a low curve all
three strikeouts for jordan have come on
the curve he gets the shutout inning and
we move to the third
and it's first and second with two out
and now they get a chance to send their
best hitter open joey gallo
that's high the bases are loaded so
now a great spot for orolis garcia
3-2
ground ball shortstop
wendell's throw a nice pick over there
at first to throw to the right field
side and diaz a very good job some great
glove work at first
also for one in the series
there's a liner that's going to be in
there with one hot the wall white's
going to play the karim bronzo
on his way to second and hustles it into
a double francisco mejia switch it or
batting left
there's a ladder into right that's going
to fall for a base hit one hop to garcia
they're going to put the stop sign up
for bronzo he had to wait to see if that
ball was going to carry
enough for garcia to maybe catch it so
he had to play it safe and it can
advance only to third and here's austin
meadows who came into the game
two of three with a home run
in his career against lyles
there's a line drive base hit first
pitch hitting
rousseau scores
and the raids are on the board to tie
this game
culverson the hitter
oh that ball
belted out to left carrying well gone
culverson stays hot in tampa
a two-run shot
and he's put the rangers back in front
he's on deck mike brasso
he's been swinging the bat well let's
see what margot can do
that's a fair ball
back toward the corner extra bases
margot on his way to second he'll be out
there
in scoring position with two outs for
mike rosso now now the o2
high fly ball back into left white's
going to go to the track he's at the
wall and that baby's gone
home run for bronzo
[Music]
what a trend for rousseau
he went 0-2 and doubled in the third
0-2 and homer hit the fourth it will be
up to solac here solac has homered
423 feet just to the left of the center
scored twice rolls this up the middle
that should get gallow to the plate
here comes the throw from phillips it's
up the line and the rangers take the
lead
4-3 on the two-out single
by nick solac
here's leonie tavares he's one for two
in the game today
is sending one toward the corner and
left double round margot makes a nice
catch before he got to the low wall
out there on the warning track river is
hitting it the opposite way and a good
jump by margot to get there in time
brandon lau first up
not very
efficient in the air deep out to left
field and back to the wall tavares makes
the catch
right up against the padding and takes
extra bases away from brandon lowe one
away with two ounce the raise will have
two men aboard on a couple walks in the
inning
and brandon lau
set to come to the plate
up here in the seventh inning now with
the rays trailing by a run
and two men on baseball
into center field it goes phillips on
his way to third the ball hits him and
now it rolls toward the dugout he's
making a dash to the plate and he scores
and all the way to third
goes to rosarina so texas throwing the
ball around and the rays are tied this
game rosarina at third lao at second
diaz at first wendell coming up
the gus home with the 2-2 swing and a
miss he struck him out got him with the
curve ball
and that'll do it here in the bottom of
the seventh inning what a crazy in it
the rays get a run without a hit the
bases are left loaded
so the rays get a base runner and
they'll get the left-handed bat of joey
wendell up there
ground ball through the open left side
diaz will turn second he's going to head
to third and the right to land in on the
corners manuel margot with a double and
a walk tonight
nice job and he foul tips it into the
glove margot down on strikes the inning
is done
hey
would be a thursday without a little
free baseball for everybody tonight
brings up adolesce garcia the one-two
and that one in the air deep out to
right field de rosarena is back
and there it goes the first home run for
garcia but he gets it tonight in extra
innings a two-run shot that puts the
rangers in front six to four so the rays
are down to their final out and it will
be yoshi tsutsugo
to pinch it here
for phillips one two
gold strike three this one is over
kennedy with his third save and the
rangers take the series in tampa bay
with a 6-4 extra innings win